This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn.
这是一个 iHeart 播客。绝对真人。嘿，你们好吗？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）带来的《Learn the Hard Way》。这个节目探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在其他地方真的无法安全开展的坦诚对话，而你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士交流。有多少男人披着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有能力，就必须这样做，听听《Learn the Hard Way》。
the hard way on the IHard radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier,
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。2%。这是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、
more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
更满足、更健康的自己。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都与同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子约会过时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。在《Look Back At It》播客节目中。从 1979 年开始，这对当时的我是个重要时刻。对大体来说，84 年意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。
With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax.
我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的嘉宾以及最喜欢的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊 80 年代。1984 年真是疯狂的一年。真是疯狂的一年。我觉得对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。2023 年，《单身汉》（Bachelor）明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控生了一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。
You doctored this particular test twice in so much, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
你曾多次篡改过这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·曼奇尼（Michael Mancini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody. I'm Gemma Speg and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world. It is so great to have you here back for another episode as we, of course, break down the psychology of our 20s. It is that time of year again. If you have been listening, all of December, you will know it is guest month where I just bring on interesting, cool, exciting people, experts, yeah, whoever I really feel interested in talking to, to, yeah, talk about their lives
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯（Laura Owens）终于面临了后果。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。大家好。我是杰玛·斯佩格（Gemma Speg），欢迎回到《The Psychology of Your 20s》，这是一个探讨我们二十多岁时最大的改变、时刻和转变，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的播客。大家好。欢迎回到节目中。欢迎回到播客，新听友们，老听友们，无论你们身在世界何处。非常高兴能邀请大家回来收听另一期节目，当然，我们将一如既往地剖析我们二十多岁的心理。又到了每年的这个时候。如果你一直在收听，整个 12 月你都会知道这是嘉宾月，我会邀请一些有趣、冷酷、令人兴奋的人、专家，是的，任何我真正感兴趣交流的人，来聊聊他们的生活，
and talk about what they're passionate about and their interests. And so far, it's been going amazing. And I feel like we've had some really cool conversations. But our most precious amazing guest is coming on today. And that is you guys. That is you all the listeners of the podcast. Every year I do one episode like this where I call out for you guys to send in your questions and your queries and your dilemmas as voice notes so that you can be featured on the podcast and today is that day we had over I don't know I think like a hundred of you yeah voicemail me call in to the podcast to be included but I chose just seven questions today to really deep dive into so I hope you enjoy and thank you
聊聊他们热衷的事情和兴趣。到目前为止，一切都进展得非常顺利。我觉得我们进行了一些非常酷的对话。但我们最珍贵、最棒的嘉宾将在今天登场。那就是你们。也就是播客的所有听众。每年我都会做这样一期节目，我号召大家把你们的问题、疑问和困惑发来语音便签，这样你们就可以登上播客，今天就是那一天。我们收到了超过，我不知道，大概有上百条你们发来的语音留言或打进播客的电话，希望能参与其中，但我今天只挑选了七个问题来进行深入探讨，所以我希望你们会喜欢，并且感谢
to all of you who contributed, whether you're featured or not. It was great. Honestly, just getting to hear your voices and being like, wow, look at all these cool people that are listening to my podcast and that want to be involved. And that's just, like, exciting. And all your different accents and, like, yeah, just different voices. It was like the coolest thing ever. So without further ado, let's get into it.
所有参与的人，无论你们是否出镜。这真的很棒。老实说，听到你们的声音，然后觉得，哇，看看所有这些听我的播客、并且想参与进来的酷人，这感觉太棒了。还有你们各种各样不同的口音，是的，各种不同的声音。这简直是有史以来最酷的事情。废话不多说，让我们切入正题。
Starting with this first question. Hi, Gemma. So I just moved back to my hometown. in the north of Spain. I've been living the past nine years in Madrid. I studied there, worked there, have all my friends there. And now I have encountered a situation
从第一个问题开始。嗨，杰玛。我刚搬回我的家乡。位于西班牙北部。过去九年在马德里生活。我在那里上学、工作，所有的朋友都在那里。现在我遇到了这样一种情况：
that I moved back to my hometown. And I actually have to create a social life for myself there. And honestly, I don't really know how to do it. I have a couple friends. They don't really seem to be that close anymore. or I feel like I have to reveal social connections, but in a way and in a place where I should have them. So it's very confusing, let alone the fact of moving back home with your parents
我搬回了家乡。实际上，我不得不在那里为自己建立社交生活。老实说，我真的不知道该怎么做。我有几个朋友。但感觉关系好像已经没那么亲密了。或者我觉得我必须重新建立社交联系，但在一个本该已经拥有这些联系的地方，以一种这种方式。这非常令人困惑，更不用说在独自生活了九年之后
after being on your own for nine years. That's definitely taken a doll of my mental health. Thank you. I love your podcasts. Thank you for your question. This is a much more common experience than I think people realize. moving back home to the places of our childhood to live with our parents after college or after a breakup or just, you know, when things go wrong and when things go right is actually something that I'm hearing about and seeing a lot of my friends more and more. It does put us in a really weird
搬回家和父母同住的事实了。这绝对对我的心理健康造成了损害。谢谢你。我喜欢你的播客。谢谢你的提问。这是一种比人们想象的要普遍得多的经历。大学毕业后、分手后，或者只是（你知道的）在事情出错或事情顺利时，搬回我们童年生活的地方与父母同住，实际上是我越来越多地听到和看到身边的朋友们在经历的事情。这确实把我们置于一个非常奇怪的
position though and I feel like this listener described it perfectly where you come back to this environment where you assume that things might be the same, where you assume you'll have friends and you don't and you have to rebuild what was once there and what you had. previously. And the thing is, there's no guidebook. No one teaches us this. There's no like intro to friendship course. There's just this assumption that you meet people and they like you and you like them and it works out well and you have enough contact that you develop a friendship. We all know there are less opportunities for that anyways. Meeting people through convenient means like school and like classes and like hobbies and work are like some of the only ways to do that.
处境中，我觉得这位听友完美地描述了这一点：你回到这个环境中，你以为事情会一如既往，你以为你会拥有朋友，但你并没有，你不得不重建曾经存在过、曾经拥有过的东西。问题是，没有指南手册。没有人教过我们这些。没有什么“友谊入门”课程。大家只是有一种假设：你遇到了人，他们喜欢你，你也喜欢他们，一切顺利，然后你们有了足够的接触，从而发展出友谊。我们都知道，无论如何，这种情况的机会越来越少了。通过学校、课程、爱好和工作等便捷途径认识人，是做到这一点的仅有的几种方法。
when you don't have school anymore, when it's kind of harder to fit in your hobbies with work, when you work remotely, like it becomes a lot more difficult. So my advice to you would be this. It's so great you already have friends there, probably I'm assuming, like you said, from childhood. Don't rely on them too heavily. Obviously, stay in contact, but consider them to just be like this amazing social safety net that you can go and talk to about this,
当你不再上学，当把爱好和工作结合起来变得更加困难，当你远程工作时，这就变得更加困难了。所以我的建议是这样的：很高兴你那里已经有朋友了，我猜，正如你所说，可能是从童年起的朋友。不要过分依赖他们。当然，保持联系，但把他们看作是一个你可以去找他们倾诉的超棒的社交安全网，
but also that you need to expand out beyond. Get as in person as possible. Do things that you feel almost embarrassed about or that are going to be a little bit weird and do them alone as a way to meet new people. And sometimes to have that desperation, like really forced you to interact with people you might not otherwise have.
同时也需要向外拓展。尽量进行面对面的接触。去做那些让你甚至感到有点尴尬，或者会觉得有点奇怪的事情，并且独自去做，以此作为结识新朋友的一种方式。有时候，这种绝望感会真正迫使你与平时可能不会接触的人进行互动。
So what I mean by that is, I need you to be going to pub nights, choir nights, pottery classes, I need you to be going to lecture nights, especially if they're free, like events at the local library, bars, trivia nights, like things like that by yourself or by inviting people that you might not know that well, just giving them the invitation and being like, hey, would you want to do this? Yes or no. Being the instigator, I talk about this so much on my episodes about friendship, but being the instigator, like, is a role that isn't filled in our society as much anymore, but everybody is craving somebody who will do it. Everybody wants the friend who's
所以我的意思是，我需要你去参加酒吧之夜、唱诗班之夜、陶艺课，我需要你去听讲座，特别是如果它们是免费的话，比如当地图书馆的活动、酒吧、知识问答之夜（Trivia nights），诸如此类的事情，你可以一个人去，或者邀请那些你可能不太熟悉的人，只要向他们发出邀请，然后说：“嘿，你想去这个吗？行还是不行。”做那个主动发起者。我在关于友谊的节目中多次谈到这一点，但做主动发起者——这个角色在我们社会中已经不再那么常见了，但每个人都在渴望有人能站出来这么做。每个人都想要这样一个朋友：
going to plan the group trips, who is going to make sure you have Wednesday night plans, make sure you have Friday night plans. If you do not have that, be that. Be the one who, like, puts their heart on the line to make community for others. And people will just flock to you. Like it's seriously, it's magnetic. How many people are looking for somebody like that in their life? The other thing I would say that you should do is, I think I talked about this in like an episode I did on moving to London. Another thing I think you should do it, and I said this, and I talked about this on my episode about moving to London, ask to be set up with friends of friends, ask if there are people that you know who know people in that area, who they think you would like,
他会策划集体旅行，会确保你们有周三晚上的计划，确保你们有周五晚上的计划。如果没有这样的人，那就由你来做。做那个勇于敞开心扉为他人建立社群的人。人们自然会向你靠拢。这真的很神奇，具有磁性。有多少人在生活中寻找这样的人啊！我要给你的另一个建议是，我想我在关于搬到伦敦的那期节目中讨论过这个。我认为你应该做的另一件事是——我提过这个，我在关于搬到伦敦的那期节目中谈到过——请求通过朋友的朋友来结识新朋友，问问你认识的人中，是否有谁在那片区域有认识的人，他们觉得你会喜欢这些人，
and just do so unabashedly and unashamedly be like, hey, I like your friend Mark, like, do you think he'd ever want to hang out with me, like platonically? Hey, I like your friend Rebecca. Like, can we do something altogether? Making those connections through other connections, like seeing humanity and friendship, like the chain link that it is, is so valuable.
然后就这样毫无顾忌、毫不羞涩地去做：“嘿，我挺喜欢你的朋友马克，你觉得他会愿意和我出去玩吗，就以纯友谊的方式？”“嘿，我喜欢你的朋友丽贝卡。我们能一起做点什么吗？”通过其他联系建立这些联系，就像看待人性和友谊那样——将其视为相连的链条——是非常宝贵的。
And also, this is unrelated, but entirely related, know that time is sometimes the most significant factor. When we look at what makes people friends, yes, similarity is important. Convenience is important. Trust is important. Time is the biggest factor. You know, Dunbar's number dictates the amount of hours you have to put into a friend or into an acquaintance for them to become a friend. It's somewhere like 200 hours. And you can look at that mountain in front of you and be like, how am I possibly going to do this, especially with multiple people? And then one day you'll be at the top of you.
另外，这虽然与此无关，但又完全相关：要知道，时间有时是最重要的因素。当我们审视是什么让人们成为朋友时，是的，相似性很重要。便利性很重要。信任很重要。时间才是最大的因素。你知道，邓巴数决定了你必须在朋友或熟人身上投入多少小时，他们才能成为真正的朋友。大概是 200 个小时左右。你可以看着面前这座大山，心想：“我怎么可能做到这一点，特别是还要面对多个人？”然后有一天，你就会登上山顶，
of the mountain being like, wow, we did that. And we are so close and we have a great relationship because we prioritize each other and because we took the small moments that we had and just ran with them and because we compounded our friendship and our interest in each other over time. So good luck. I'm sure it's going to be amazing. And hopefully I get an update from you in a couple of months' time being like, hey, I'm feeling a lot better about this. So yeah. Okay, who are we going to hear from next? Let's listen to this one here. Hi, Gemma.
感叹道：“哇，我们做到了。我们关系这么好，我们有着极好的关系，因为我们把彼此放在首位，因为我们抓住了我们拥有的每一个微小时刻并为之努力，因为随着时间的推移，我们加深了我们的友谊和对彼此的兴趣。”所以祝你好运。我相信这一定会很棒。希望几个月后我能收到你的近况更新，说：“嘿，我对现状感觉好多了。”所以，是的。好了，接下来我们要听谁的？让我们听听这一条。嗨，杰玛。
So I just got out of a three-year relationship, and I'm realizing that I centered my entire identity around him and his parents. And all my time and energy kind of went into his goals for our life. So I guess my question is, how do I grow back to my own roots and figure out what I want from this life? from my 20s. And I just wanted to say, thank you, Gemma, on behalf of all of your listeners. I think I re-listened to the episode where you talked about when you know it's time to walk away or when to know how to know when it's time to walk away about 10 times before I did walk away. But you have changed my life and we just want to encourage you.
我刚结束一段三年的感情，我意识到我把整个身份都建立在他和他的父母身上。我所有的精力和时间似乎都投入到了他对我们生活的规划中。所以我想我的问题是：我该如何重回自己的根基，弄清楚我在这段生活中、在二十多岁时真正想要什么？我只是想代表你所有的听众对你说声谢谢，杰玛。我想在我真正决定离开前，关于你谈论“如何知道是时候放手了”的那期节目，我大概重听了十遍。但你改变了我的生活，我们只想鼓励你：
keep doing what you're doing. Oh, that's so sweet. They always make me, I always feel so embarrassed, but I appreciate, I appreciate the love. And I'm just going to say, I am so excited for you. And maybe that's not what you want to hear, but oh my God, I am so excited for you. And for this next chapter and how freaking amazing it's going to end up being. One of my best friends is going through a breakup right now. I gave her that same advice. Breakups, especially with someone you've been with for a while are chaotic and deeply painful and sometimes the grief and the guilt and all of that tangles up together and feels inescapable. It's also just like such fertile ground for growth. You've already lost this relationship. Sometimes it feels like what else do I have to lose?
坚持做你正在做的事。哦，太甜了。他们总是让我感到非常不好意思，但我很感激这份爱。我只想说，我为你感到兴奋！也许这并不是你想听到的，但天哪，我真的为你感到兴奋。为你即将迎来的下一篇章，以及它最终会变得多么不可思议而感到兴奋。我最好的朋友之一现在正经历分手。我给了她同样的建议。分手，特别是与一个你交往了一段时间的人分手，是混乱且极度痛苦的，有时悲伤、内疚和所有这些情绪交织在一起，让人感觉无处可逃。但这也是成长的一片沃土。你已经失去了这段感情。有时你会觉得，我还有什么可失去的呢？
So you're just like so much more, you have so much more room for experimentation with your life. and because you're just so in touch with who you are because you're not distracted by having this partner. You're not distracted by dating. You're so in your own head and you're in your own thoughts about your feelings. What is going to come next often appears to you very rapidly and in like great moments of inspiration. Like genuinely that is how this podcast started was after a breakup because it's just like every emotion is on the surface. You're able to intuitively feel. feel them better and you're also keen to do something with your energy and with your time. So I'm super excited for you.
所以你会有更多的空间去对生活进行实验。而且因为你与真正的自己如此贴近，没有被拥有这样一个伴侣所分心。你没有被约会所分心。你的脑海里全都是关于自己感受的思考。接下来会发生什么，往往会非常迅速地浮现，并伴随着美妙的灵感时刻。说实话，这个播客就是在一场分手后开始的，因为当时每一种情绪都浮于表面。你能够凭直觉去感受，
I honestly think it's going to be great. My advice for reclaiming your life back now that you've dissented this man or this person and his family and it sounds like all of his friends as well is to just firstly reconnect with your old friends. Be completely honest and say, hey, I'm sorry. like that relationship took a lot from me and I, you know, want to say I'm not the person or didn't think I was going to be the person that that happened to, but it did. And if you have me back in your life, I'd be very grateful, be very earnest with your feelings
能够更好地感受它们，并且你也渴望用你的精力和时间做点什么。所以我为你超级兴奋。我真的认为这会很棒。我关于收回自己生活的建议是：既然你已经不再以这个男人（或这个人）及其家人、听起来还有他所有的朋友为中心了，那么首先要做的就是与老朋友重新建立联系。完全诚实地说：“嘿，很抱歉。那段感情占据了我太多的精力，我（你知道的）想说，我本不是那种人，也从没想过自己会变成那种经历这种事的人，但事实确实发生了。如果你能让我回到你的生活中，我会非常感激。”对老朋友的感情要表现得非常诚挚，
towards old friendships. And then similar to the advice I gave to the last listener, just hobby your life to the max. I want to see a full calendar. Some people say like distraction after a breakup is just avoidance. no, it's not. It's completely not. It's a healthy coping mechanism you are taking your pain and I want you to be putting it into all different avenues. Anything that you've ever thought you might like or that you wanted to explore. Now is your chance because you just have so much free time. You're just such an open soul and an open wound. There's so much gushing out that like it's just going to ignite so many fires and it's just going to be honestly. pretty wonderful and spectacular what you end up discovering about yourself.
然后，类似于我给上一位听友的建议，让你的生活充满各种爱好。我希望能看到一个满满当当的日程表。有些人说分手后的分心只是逃避。不，根本不是。这完全不是。这是一种健康的应对机制，你把痛苦引导到各个不同的渠道中去。任何你曾经认为自己可能会喜欢或想要探索的东西。现在是你的机会，因为你拥有如此多的空闲时间。你是一个如此开放的灵魂，也是一道尚未愈合的伤口。有太多的情感涌现出来，它会点燃你内心的许多热情，最终你所发现的关于自己的事情，老实说，将会是
I will also say read, read, read, or listen to podcasts, listen to audio books. But some of the times the best way to find yourself is by discovering how other people did it and hearing their stories of how they became passionate about something and how they discovered the narrative of their life and how they, you know, came back from hard circumstances. like taking yourself out of your mind and out of your circumstances and seeing other people's lives and what they've done with them can be deeply inspirational and I think also gives you some of that emotional distance from the breakup that we need when we're in those like early days of healing so we don't feel like this is all that life is so I keep saying this best of luck like
相当美妙和壮观的。我还要说：阅读、阅读、再阅读，或者听播客、听有声书。但有时候，找回自我的最好方法是了解其他人是如何做到的，听听他们如何对某事产生热情的故事、他们如何发现自己的人生叙事，以及他们如何（你知道的）从艰难的环境中走出来。把你的思维和处境抽离出来，去看看别人的生活以及他们用生活做了什么，会给你带来深深的启发，而且我认为这也为你提供了我们需要的那种与分手的感情距离，这样在疗愈的早期阶段，我们就不会觉得生活仅此而已。所以我一直在说，祝你好运。
I'm rooting for you we have so many episodes on this by the way we just just did one recently on decentering romance in your 20s that I think you personally would really enjoy. So, yeah, there's so much, so much advice I could give. I'm going to keep it small and simple. Hobby your life up. earnestly re-approach friends. Read, engage with material beyond your circumstances and beyond your breakup and just know that you've freaking got this and it's going to be amazing even if it's not great right now. All right. Let's move on to our next question. there, I wanted to ask your opinion on navigating people not liking you in your 20s. Whether it's jealousy or your personalities clash, I think this is an experience many people go
我支持你。顺便说一句，我们有很多关于这个主题的节目，我们最近刚做了一期关于“在二十岁时将浪漫去中心化”的节目，我想你个人会非常喜欢。所以，是的，我可以给出很多很多的建议。我将保持简短。让你的生活充满爱好。真诚地重新接触朋友。阅读、接触超越你目前处境和超越分手的素材，并要知道你绝对可以搞定这一切，即使现在感觉并不那么美好。好了，让我们进入下一个问题。在这里，我想问问你对于在二十岁时如何应对“别人不喜欢你”这一现象的看法。无论是出于嫉妒还是性格冲突，我认为这是许多人都会经历的
through, but when it is happening to you, you feel really alone and like it's only ever happened to you. I know you've made past episodes about the fear of being perceived and how friendships can change or end, but I'm talking about specifically when people are purposely mean and hateful towards you. What skills you are. What skills you are. you can use to process those emotions and move forward from it, the feeling of being misunderstood by others and judged by others and how not to let that shake your core or kind of send you into this very, very big spiral. I just find that a lot of episodes are very, very good to relate to, but when people are purposely mean in life, it's not perceiving them to be like that.
一种经历，但当它真正发生在你身上时，你会觉得非常孤独，觉得这种事只发生在你一个人身上。我知道你以前做过关于“被注视的恐惧”以及友谊如何改变或结束的节目，但我具体指的是当人们故意对你刻薄、充满敌意时，你可以用什么技能来处理这些情绪并从中走出来，那种被他人误解和评判的感觉，以及如何不让这种感觉动摇你的核心，或者陷入那种非常非常严重的情绪螺旋中。我发现很多节目都非常有共鸣，但在生活中当人们故意刻薄时，这并不是对他们的一种感知，
it's a real experience. So I would just ask your opinion on how to navigate that, how not to become consumed by people's negativity towards you or being misunderstood, and how to just move forward from it all and not be held down by the weight of it. Thank you. Oh, I love this question. I love this question because it's been something I've been thinking about a lot and I love that you made that distinction. It's not perception. This is actually happening. I've had this happen a bit recently with just like some online hate that I've been getting, which I have this theory that if like you reach a certain level of followers or certain level of listeners, like, that's when like people just come and they find you and they want to bring you down and they want to be not just
这是一种真实的经历。所以我想问问你的看法：如何应对这种情况，如何不被他人对你的负面情绪或误解所吞噬，以及如何从中走出来，不被它的重量所压垮。谢谢。哦，我太喜欢这个问题的。我太喜欢这个问题了，因为这也是我一直在思考的一个问题，我很高兴你做了这种区分。这不是主观感知。这确实在发生。我最近也遇到了一些类似的情况，就是遇到了一些网上对我发起的恶意攻击，我有一个理论：如果你达到了某种粉丝量或某种听众规模，那正是人们蜂拥而至找到你、想要把你拉下来、不仅想要
critical because criticism is actually something I enjoy and that I do respond to. It's going to say respond well to, I don't, but I do try and respond better to. But it's this kind of person that just like maliciously gets something out of making your day worse and hating on you and ruining your reputation and being hurtful and spiteful. And when I encounter these people, I do this thought exercise that really helps me have not just neutrality but kindness towards these people because really my ambition and my goal is when this happens is to have forgiveness and love towards these people because I find that that's like the strongest deepest antidote to them being able to hurt you and how I do it is I think about
进行批评（因为批评其实是我喜欢且会回应的事——本该说“积极回应”，我其实并没有，但我确实在努力做出更好的回应）的人，而是那种从让你的一天变得糟糕、讨厌你、毁你名誉、恶意中伤和恶毒行径中获得某种恶意快感的人。当我遇到这些人时，我会做一个思维练习，这真正帮助我不仅对这些人保持中立，甚至能保持善良，因为实际上我的雄心和目标是在发生这种情况时，对这些人抱有宽恕和爱，因为我发现这是对抗他们伤害你的最强有力、最深层的解药。我是怎么做到的呢？我会回想
the times when I've been in that mindset when I have been maybe not hateful I don't think that I actually really don't think I ever have been hateful but what I've been angered at somebody, when I've been judgmental of somebody, when I've perhaps gossiped about somebody, when I've been furious at somebody who cut me off. And I think about how the reaction that left on my body and on my heart and on my mind, and it's never been good. It's never been good. It's always left me exhausted, kind of terrified, tired. I feel the ugliness. in me, right? It's that roll-dial quote from the twits. Like, if you are, you could be the most beautiful person in the world, but if you think terrible, ugly thoughts about others, you'll never be
那些我曾处于那种心态的时刻——当我可能并不是充满仇恨（我不认为自己曾有过仇恨，真的不认为自己曾对谁充满仇恨），但当我生某人的气时，当我评判某人时，当我可能八卦过某人时，当我对外卖员或插队的人感到愤怒时。我会回想这种反应在我的身体、心脏和心灵上留下的印记，它从来都不是好的。它从来都不是好的。它总是让我筋疲力尽、心有余悸、感到疲惫。我感到了自己身上的丑陋，
truly beautiful. Meanwhile, like, you could be objectively unattractive, but if you think good, positive thoughts, beauty will always, like, shine out of your face like a million flowers. I'm obviously butchering that quote, but I think about that and I think about how this cruelty and mean this must be manifesting in them to such an intensity that it's able to be projected onto you. And having that empathy also makes me realize this has nothing to do with me. 90% of people's opinions, criticisms, perceptions of you, cruelty towards you is just a real deep reflection of something within them. And I know that's probably advice or things that you hear.
对吧？就像罗尔德·达尔（Roald Dahl）在《蠢特夫妇》里说的那样：“如果你拥有世界上最美妙的思想，它们会像阳光一样从你的脸上倾泻而出，你会永远看起来可爱。”与此同时，你可以长相平平，但如果你心存善念，美丽就会像百万朵花一样从你的脸上闪耀出来。我显然把这句名言给记混了，但我想到了这一点，想到了这种残忍和刻薄一定在他们内心以如此强烈的程度显现出来，以至于它能够被投射到你身上。拥有这种同理心也让我意识到，这与我毫无关系。人们 90% 的意见、批评、看法以及对你的残忍，其实都只是他们内心深处某种东西的真实反映。我知道这可能是你经常听到的
you hear that a lot and then when you really sink into that like sometimes it just hits when you're like oh gosh yeah like they want to pull me down because to see me succeed would prove everything about them that they don't like they want to criticize me because i'm friends with somebody else because deeply they are deeply jealous because they don't feel worthy of friendship in the first place there's all these like deep psychological cognitive explanations for why people behave like this. Understanding that more is the first step. And the second step is not just to ignore it, is to appreciate it. Take what you can from it and then just let it go.
建议或观点，但当你真正沉浸其中时，有时它会猛然击中你，让你觉得：“哦，天哪，是的——他们想把我拉下去，因为看到我成功就会证明他们身上那些他们自己不喜欢的东西；他们想批评我和其他人交朋友，是因为他们内心深处极度嫉妒，因为他们觉得自己根本不配拥有友谊。”对于人们为什么会有这种行为，有很多深层的心理学和认知解释。更多地理解这一点是第一步。第二步不仅是忽略它，而是去感激它。从中汲取你能吸收的东西，然后放手。
Take what you can from it because sometimes like there is genuine criticism in someone's words. Sometimes there's not. But if there is even a nugget of it, that's great. They've given you a gift. The rest of it, you can literally just throw. throw away. Sometimes getting existential and realizing how short life is is also really valuable to me. Not just how short life is, but how small each of us is and how small our circumstances are
从中汲取你能吸收的东西，因为有时别人的话里确实有真诚的批评。有时则没有。但即使有一点点，那也是好的。他们送了你一份礼物。至于其余的部分，你完全可以扔掉。有时变得有点存在主义，意识到生命是多么短暂，对我来说也很有价值。不仅是生命多么短暂，而是我们每个人是多么渺小，我们的处境
in the broad scheme of things is really valuable to me. And it's not, I don't do it to make myself feel bad or feel like I'm overreacting, not at all. I just do it because it gives me perspective. And it allows my center, my emotional orbit, to not be this other person because neither of us really matter that much. Their opinion doesn't really matter about me. Like, their opinion of me doesn't really matter. My opinion of them doesn't really matter. And having that kind of detachment almost and that big picture out of earth experience or perspective
在大局中是多么渺小，这对我很有价值。我这么做并不是为了让自己感觉糟糕或觉得自己反应过度，完全不是。我这么做只是为了获得宏观视角。这让我的中心、我的情感轨道不至于被另一个人所左右，因为我们两个其实都没有那么重要。他们对我的看法并不那么重要。我对他们的看法也并不那么重要。拥有这种超脱感以及宏观的、上帝视角般的体验或视角，
lets you just roll with the punches a little bit more. My final piece of advice on this is like, if you can, I know it's hard. if you work with somebody or their family. I'm a big fan of the block button. You know what? Like, you just block them. Just don't be part of their life as much as you possibly can. And I know that you're going to think that's going to change how your friends may perceive you,
能让你面对挫折时更加游刃有余。我对此的最后一条建议是：如果可以的话（我知道这很难），如果你和某人共事或那是你的亲戚，我非常支持“拉黑”按钮。你知道吗？直接拉黑他们。尽可能不要再成为他们生活的一部分。我知道你可能会认为这会改变你的朋友们对你的看法，
especially if you're in a friendship group together or anything like that. But, you know, people make up their own minds about people and they see a lot more than you think they do. and they can tell a lot more than you need to tell them. So let people make their own opinions and own judgments about these people. I'm sure they will definitely come around to the right opinion and see what is happening. Don't try and force them and just do whatever it takes to, yeah, I guess protect your peace. I hope that's the advice that you were looking for and best of luck. Okay, we're going to take a short break here, but when we return, we have some more listener questions.
特别是如果你和他们在同一个朋友圈里的话。但是，人们会对别人做出自己的判断，他们看到的比你想象的要多得多，而且他们能看出的东西也比你需要告诉他们的要多得多。所以，让人们对这些人形成他们自己的意见和判断吧。我相信他们最终一定会得出正确的结论，看清到底发生了什么。不要试图强求，尽一切努力去——是的，我想是保护你的内心的平静。我希望这是你在寻找的建议，祝你好运。好了，我们要在这里稍作休息，但稍后回来时，我们还有更多听友提出的问题。
So stay tuned. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong.
所以请继续收听。2%。这就是在有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中培养心理韧性、体能和抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和体能专家等人进行对话，抛开那些主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们曾真诚地相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们弄错了。
Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. There's two golden rules that any man should live by. Rule one, never mess with a country girl. You play stupid games, you get stupid prizes. And rule two, never mess with her friends either. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你最终会迎来一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的自己。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。那是 iHeart Radio 应用程序上的 T-W-O-Persent，或者无论你在哪里获得播客。任何男人都应该遵守两条黄金法则。法则一，千万不要惹乡下女孩。玩愚蠢的游戏，就会得到愚蠢的奖品。法则二，也千万不要惹她的朋友。我们总是说，相信你的好姐妹。
I'm Anna Sinfield, and in this new season of the girlfriends... Oh my God, this is the same man. A group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist. I felt like I got hit by a truck. I thought, how could this happen to me? The cops didn't seem to care. So they take matters into their own hands. I said, oh, hell no.
我是安娜·辛菲尔德（Anna Sinfield），在这个新季的《The Girlfriends》中……天哪，这是同一个人。一群女性发现她们都与同一个劣迹斑斑的骗子约会过。我感觉自己像被卡车撞了。我想，这种事怎么会发生在我身上？警察似乎并不在乎。所以她们决定自己采取行动。我说，哦，见鬼去吧。
I vowed. I will be his last target. He's going to get what he deserves. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-taped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Blitz.
我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他会得到应有的惩罚。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《The Girlfriends: Trust Me, Babe》。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在 VMA 颁奖典礼上拍打小金（Little Kim）的胸部两次吗？或者当坎耶（Kanye）说乔治·布什（George Bush）
didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English.
不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back At It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。
Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
每期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）畅谈 80 年代可卡因的节目。需要说明的是，84 年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为可卡因。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second. episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. So, oh. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
我愿意在白天谈论可卡因，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的线索。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在台面上。所以，哦。谢谢你把话说完。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kier Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month,
我觉得对黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人最重要的年份之一。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，
I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
我带来了我自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与许多不可思议的嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹（Tripp Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth, or are you a good person because you're freed? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust.
因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得作为一个在世的好人很重要，还是你觉得自己是个好人是因为你免受谴责？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对是。那是两个不同层面的信任。
I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd, found himself at the center of a paternity scandal.
我希望你真正地做一个好人。和我——凯尔·盖恩斯——一起，在我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》中，就疗愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的 iHeartRadio App。搜索 Learn the Hard Way 并立即收听。2023 年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。
The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected.
随后的家庭法庭听证会暴露出她故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾多次篡改过这份特定的检测报告，对吗？我篡改过一次检测。这动用了大批网络侦探才破了案。我希望人们能看到他们的纳税被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。
They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through. the same thing. Greg, a lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap.
他们揭露了一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格，一个女同性恋者，迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我惊呆了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《Love Trapped》。
Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Maricopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over
劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县突发新闻：劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有诈骗罪。这件事还没完，
until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Okay, welcome back. Let's listen to some further questions from you guys are listeners, starting with this next one.
直到正义在亚利桑那州得到伸张。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。好的，欢迎回来。让我们来听听你们这些听友提出的更多问题，从下一个问题开始。
Hey, Gemma. This is a note from London, England. Very excited to have you in the city soon. Just really love your podcast, and it really, really resonates with so many of my friends and me, especially when we've hit this weird late 20s era, struggling post-COVID and trying to navigate our ones. way through this strange time. One dilemma I had that I'm really struggling with is every year I think
嗨，杰玛。这是一条来自英格兰伦敦的留言。非常高兴你很快就要来到这座城市。我真的很喜欢你的播客，它真的、真的引起了我和我的许多朋友的共鸣，特别是在我们迎来了这个奇怪的二十代末期时代、在疫情后苦苦挣扎并试图在这个奇怪的时期寻找出路的时候。我有一个纠结了很久的困惑是：每年我都以为
that I'm going to get closer to figuring it all out, quote on quote, with my career, with relationships, with money, with what I want to do. And the older I get, the more and more I'm actually feeling like I know less and less. I don't know what I'm doing. I'm struggling to save money because I'm torn between living in a city that's cool versus saving for a house. I don't know whether to travel. I don't like my job. I feel so confused and lost. And I'd just like to ask, do you think we ever figure it all out?
自己离把一切都“搞清楚”更近了一步——无论是职业、人际关系、金钱还是我想做的事。但随着年龄的增长，我越来越觉得我其实知道得越来越少。我不知道自己在做什么。我很难存下钱，因为我在“住在很酷的城市”和“存钱买房”之间左右为难。我不知道是否应该去旅行。我讨厌我的工作。我感到如此困惑和迷茫。我只想问：你认为我们真的能把一切都搞清楚吗？
And what is the best course of action when you genuinely don't know which path in front of you is the right one to take? Thank you. Whoa, big questions. Quite simply, no, I don't think. can we figure it all out. I also have this deep philosophy that we're not meant to. That when we stop striving, like, what's the point of being here? You know, what's the point of like inhabiting this world and like, and learning more? Like to have all the solutions and to know why it all happens and to have it all figured out and to have the perfect plan and for that plan to be executed kind of takes
当你真的不知道面前哪条路才是正确的前进方向时，最好的行动方案是什么？谢谢。哇，好大的问题。很简单，不，我不认为我们能把一切都搞清楚。我也有这样一种深层的哲学观点：我们本就不该如此。当我们停止奋斗时，（你知道的）在这里的意义是什么？（你知道的）占据这个世界并了解更多事情的意义是什么？拥有所有的解决方案，知道这一切为什么会发生，一切都已明了，拥有完美的计划，并且该计划得以执行，这其实把
all of the fun out of it. Obviously, life's peaks and troughs can be really, really tough sometimes and like a real freaking struggle. And I'm sure this advice or this perspective is maybe not the one some of you want to hear, but really like, this is life. Life is actually not the times when it's all going well. It's the times that you struggle and you push through and you have to just trust your instinct and trust your desires and just kind of get some battle scars from it all. Like that's really the proof that you are living. It's definitely difficult when you're like, there's a million fires going right now. Which one do I, which one do I address first?
所有的乐趣都剥夺了。显然，生活中的高峰和低谷有时会非常非常艰难，（你知道的）就像是一场真正的硬仗。我确信这个建议或这个视角可能不是你们有些人想听的，但实际上——这就是生活。生活其实并不是指一切都很顺利的那些时光。而是指你挣扎、坚持、不得不依靠自己的直觉和欲望、并从中留下一些战斗伤痕的那些时光。（你知道的）这才是你正在生活的真正证明。当你面对“现在有无数场火在烧，我该先处理哪一个”时，这绝对是困难的。
I think you just have to ride the wave and just break it down one at a time. You hate your job. Like, you know what? That can be your focus for six months. Let's get this part of life feeling good for. now and maybe that will change but just making sure that you are taking deliberate actions towards the areas where you feel dissatisfaction is really important so that you don't just feel at the behest of your circumstances. What was the second part of that question as well? Like how do
我想你只需要顺其自然，一步一步来。你讨厌你的工作。比如，你知道吗？那可以作为你接下来的六个月的重点。我们先让生活的这部分感觉好一点，也许以后会有所改变，但确保你对感到不满意的领域采取深思熟虑的行动是非常重要的，这样你就不会觉得完全受制于环境。那个问题的第二部分是什么来着？比如怎么
you know when to make what decision to make? What I always go with, because again there's no right answer is I just think about which one I'm going to regret not doing the most. You know, what is thing that I'm maybe going to turn around at 70, 80, God willing, and be like, God, I wish I had done that. Can I see myself talking about this opportunity I have now like that? Can I see myself, you know, not traveling and having that thought? Can I see myself, you know, not staying in the city a little bit longer and having that thought? Whichever one I have the most like kind of gut reaction of of maybe future regret towards is the one I know that I should do. And you can do pro cons list with that as well.
你知道什么时候该做出什么决定吗？我通常会选择的是——因为同样没有标准答案——去想哪一个是我不做会最后悔的。你知道的，有什么事可能是我到了70、85岁（如果上帝保佑的话）时回想起来会说：“天哪，我真希望当时做了那件事。”我能想象自己以后会像那样谈论现在拥有的这个机会吗？我能想象自己不去旅行然后为此后悔吗？我能想象自己不在这个城市多待一会儿然后产生这种想法吗？对于哪个选项，我内心对“未来可能会后悔”的直觉反应最强烈，我就会知道我应该选哪个。你也可以用它来列出利弊清单。
But part of like figuring life out as much as you can or making right decisions, it's just getting really clear on what your gut is telling you. And really clear on what your values are, what you really want to, what you really want to see happen in your life in the next five years and what is going to be aligned with that versus what is going to detract from that. One more exercise I do that I find really helpful is one of my friends actually told me about this. And I even put it in my book, which is don't imagine everything going right. Don't imagine your dream life.
但弄清楚你尽可能的认清生活或者做出正确决定的部分，就是弄清楚你的直觉在告诉你什么。并且非常清楚你的价值观是什么，在未来五年里你真正想在生活中发生什么，什么与此相符，而什么又会背离这一点。我做的另一个练习，我发现它真的很有帮助，其实是我一个朋友告诉我的。我甚至把它写进了我的书里，那就是：不要想象一切都进行得很顺利。不要去想象你的梦想生活。
Imagine a day in your life in 10, 15 years. That's a really happy day. And what are you doing? Who are you seeing? Who are you around? Who do you have dinner with? What kind of bed sheets do you wake up on? in what neighborhood?
想象一下你在10年、15年后的生活中的某一天。那是非常快乐的一天。你在做什么？你在见谁？你在谁身边？你和谁一起吃晚饭？你在什么样的床单上醒来？在哪个街区？
What about that makes you so happy? What about that future life makes you happy? How can you bring that into your life now? Not just in terms of decisions to get you to that future, but in terms of just like daily feelings of joy. What can you do right now to make this a great moment that you'll appreciate even if it's not exactly where you want to be here? So yeah, that is my advice for that lovely listener.
是什么让你如此快乐？未来生活的哪一点让你感到快乐？你如何把它带入你现在的生活中？不仅仅是在做出能让你走向未来的决定的层面上，而是仅仅在日常的快乐感受方面。你现在可以做什么来让这一刻变得美好，即使它不完全是你想要呆的地方，你也会感激它？所以，是的，这就是我给这位可爱听众的建议。
And also thank you for welcoming me to London. should have addressed that. I really appreciate that. Hopefully I get to meet you in an event soon and we can talk more about it. I feel like I can say a lot more. All right. Our next question, here we go. Hi, Gemma. So my dilemma is how do you deal with evolving friendships and how do you end a friendship in your 20? So I have a friend that I've known for many, many years and we were very, very close for a very a long time. But over the past couple years, there's been a build-up of some things that have made me think that this is a friendship that no longer serves me. And it's kind of been a combination of the way I've been treated in a few different situations and also the fact that we are
还有，谢谢你欢迎我来到伦敦。我本该提到这一点的。我真的很感激。希望我很快能在某个活动上见到你，我们可以聊更多。我觉得我还能说很多。好了。我们的下一个问题，我们开始吧。嗨，杰玛。所以我的困惑是，你如何处理不断演变的友情，以及如何在20多岁时结束一段友情？所以，我有一个认识了很多很多年的朋友，我们在很长一段时间里都非常非常亲密。但在过去几年里，有些事情逐渐积压，让我觉得这是一段不再适合我的友谊。这可以说是几种不同情况下我被对待的方式的结合，也是因为我们
leading very different lives from each other. And a lot of the decisions she makes go against my values and things that I really believe in as a person. And so for that reason, I've been finding it hard to still be friends with her. And anyway, without going to too much detail, this is a friendship that I no longer want in my life. And I'm not really sure how to end it. I have brought up with her a little bit about how I don't agree with some of the things that she's done.
过着截然不同的生活。她做出的大多数决定都违背了我的价值观，违背了我作为一个真正信仰的人的原则。因此，出于这个原因，我发现很难继续和她做朋友。不管怎样，在不讲太多细节的情况下，这是我不再想要留在生活中的友谊。我其实已经跟她提过一点，关于我不同意她所做的一些事情。
And I've asked her not to speak to me about some of the stuff that. she's doing because it makes me uncomfortable. And she's been fine about that, but she's also been quite resistant to any suggestion that, hey, maybe we're very different people than we were when we became friends. So how do I kind of move forward? Okay, this is a common dilemma. And I'm going to be completely honest, it is one that I have definitely had before. And I think I've done the wrong thing.
而且我要求她不要跟我谈论她正在做的某些事情，因为这让我感到不舒服。她对此表现得很好，但对于任何“嘿，也许我们和成为朋友时已经是非常不同的人了”的暗示，她也相当抵触。那我该怎么继续前进呢？好吧，这是一个常见的困惑。我必须完全诚实地说，这绝对是我以前也经历过的一次。而且我觉得我当时做错了。
So knowing that, I'm going to hopefully give you some advice on. how to do the right thing. Firstly, the care that you have for your friend, despite the fact that you don't want to be friends with her anymore, is really beautiful and shows that you actually probably deserve much better friends. The fact that you're wanting to do this with kindness and with love is just a really big, huge testament to your character, so I want you to know that, just to get that clear off the bat.
所以知道了这一点，我希望能给你一些关于如何做正确事情的建议。首先，尽管你不想再和她做朋友了，但你对朋友的关怀真的很美好，这表明你其实可能值得拥有更好的朋友。你希望以善意和爱意来处理这件事，这简直是对你人品的一个巨大证明，所以我希望你知道这一点，从一开始就把这一点弄清楚。
I'm hearing that you've tried to have these conversations before. I think that if you are truly committed and truly in your mind, like we are not going to be friends anymore, you need to sit this friend down and have a huge heart to heart. I have had friendships in the past not to go into too much detail because I still have a lot of respect for these people, but that just haven't worked with we were different people. And because we, our characters just weren't aligned, our values weren't aligned. Doesn't mean they were bad. doesn't mean they were awful.
我听说你以前尝试过进行这些对话。我认为，如果你是真正坚定的，并且在内心深处坚信——我们不再是朋友了，你需要让这位朋友坐下来，进行一次推心置腹的大长谈。我过去也有过这样的友谊，为了不涉及太多细节，因为我对这些人仍然抱有很大敬意，但就是因为我们是不同的人，所以无法继续下去了。因为我们，我们的性格就是不合拍，我们的价值观不相符。这并不意味着他们是坏人。这并不意味着他们很糟糕。
There were things they did that hurt me that I didn't agree with and probably things that I did as well. The biggest regret I have is that I didn't have the, I don't know, courage, grace, knowledge, foresight, to have a sit-down conversation with that person and say, our friendship meant so much to me. And I really do love you and I care about you, almost like a breakup, but like, you know, our time has come.
他们做过伤害我的事，我不同意，可能我做的事也一样。我最大的遗憾是，我没有那种——我不知道，勇气、风度、见解、远见，去和那个人坐下来谈谈，说：我们的友谊对我很重要。我真的很爱你，我在乎你，就像一次分手那样，但你知道的，我们的时间到了。
Our time has come to move on and I hope you can understand it. and here are my reasons. And here's your space to talk about maybe probably some of your grievances or some of your reasons. But here is my love on a platter. Take it with you. You'll always have it. It's yours to keep.
我们前行的时刻已经到来，我希望你能理解。这里是我的理由。这里是你的空间，你可以去谈谈你可能存在的怨气或一些理由。但这是我呈上的一片心意。请带上它。你将永远拥有它。它是属于你的。
But we need to find a new direction. So I think writing down what's really driving this feeling, being, having the courage to have a sit down chat with her, knowing that you might get a terrible bad reaction, but also knowing that later down the line, I think she'll probably appreciate the closure is super important. I think, and if that's not what you want to do, and if there's something else, you know, a different way you want to approach it, just think, if I was in her shoes, how would I want the situation to be approached?
但我们需要寻找一个新的方向。所以我觉得，写下真正驱使这种感觉的原因，有勇气和她坐下来聊天，虽然知道你可能会得到糟糕的负面反应，但也知道在未来的某个时刻，我想她可能会感激这种了结，这是超级重要的。我认为，如果这不是你想做的，如果还有别的，你知道的，你想用不同的方式来处理它，只需设想一下：如果我是她，我会希望别人如何处理这种情况？
If I, because it sounds like she probably doesn't know that this is coming, but like, if I had this huge character flaw or this part about me that, you know, I wasn't really ready to address and it was going to cost me a friendship, how would I want somebody to approach that in the most honest, kind, gentle way? And that's a question you have to answer for yourself, but that is the way that you should do it. Good luck. You sound like a genuinely lovely person. And I'm really sorry that the friendship has ended up this way, but it is unfortunately a part of life. And you are handling it with grace. So that's the best we can do. Okay. Next question.
如果我——因为听起来她可能不知道这即将发生，但是——如果我有这种巨大的性格缺陷，或者我身上这一部分，你知道的，我还没有准备好去面对，而它将让我失去一段友谊，我会希望别人用最诚实、善良、温柔的方式来处理这个问题？这是一个你需要自己回答的问题，但这就是你应该去做的方式。祝你好运。听起来你是一个真正可爱的人。我真的很遗憾这段友谊最终会变成这样，但遗憾的是，这是生活的一部分。而你正以优雅的方式处理它。所以这是我们能做到的最好的了。好的。下一个问题。
Hi, Gemma. So in order for me to ask my question, I just want to give a little bit of background information and context. I am 25. I am married. I'm in my final year of pursuing a degree in psychology. I want to pursue a master's. I am very fulfilled in my hobbies and my friendships and the plans that I have for my life. However, my husband and I live in a different country in a different time zone.
嗨，杰玛。为了让我能提出我的问题，我只想提供一些背景信息和环境。我25岁。我结婚了。我正处于攻读心理学学位的最后一年。我想攻读硕士学位。我在我的爱好、友谊以及我为人生的计划中感到非常满足。然而，我和我丈夫住在另一个国家、另一个时区，
than our family and majority of our friends. And even with all of this and the separation and distance, I still have tremendous eldest daughter guilt. A lot of times it still feels like some comments or some jabs about being far away, not being present for certain things, not completely pursuing the ideas that my parents had for me in my life. I still feel pressured, even though I'm so far away. And I was just hoping that you have any advice that you can give me on this.
远离我们的家人和大部分朋友。即便这一切以及分离和距离都存在，我仍然有着巨大的长女内疚感。很多时候，关于离得很远、没有出席某些事情、没有完全按照我父母为我的人生制定的想法去发展的评论或挖苦，依然让我觉得压力重重，尽管我离得那么远。我只是希望你能给我一些关于这方面的建议。
I loved your episode about how to feel like yourself again and how to stop seeking external validation. But I was just wondering if you have any practical advice for me. I love your podcast. Sincerely a South African that just wants to be a dang psychologist one day. Oh my gosh. I love. First thing, I love your accent. Anytime I hear a South African accent, and always like is so interesting and like crispy to me.
我非常喜欢你关于如何找回自我以及如何停止寻求外部认可的那期节目。但我只是想知道你是否能给我一些实用的建议。我太喜欢你的播客了。真心署名：一个梦想有一天能成为心理学家的南非人。天哪，我太喜欢了。首先，我爱你的口音。每当我听到南非口音，总是觉得它那么有趣，听起来对我很清脆。
Like, I don't know. I love a South African accent. So what a joy to listen to your question. Elder's daughter guilt is real and I have experienced it. And so have many of my eldest daughter friends, this is actually a really important stage in life that you would know as somebody saying psychology that everybody has to go through of like, what's the priority? me or the family individual preferences or obligation the collective or my own personal kind of ambitions and goals and based on our conditioning especially as women and eldest daughters can feel like choosing any of the left hand options any of the individual preference passion like personal ambition
就像，我不知道。我很喜欢南非口音。所以听你的问题真是一种享受。长女的内疚感是真实存在的，我曾经历过。我的许多长女朋友也经历过，这其实是人生中一个非常重要的阶段，作为学过心理学的人你会知道，每个人都必须经历这一关，比如：什么是优先级？我还是家庭？个人偏好还是义务？集体还是我个人的雄心和目标？根据我们的社会规训，尤其是作为女性和长女，选择左边的任何选项——任何个人偏好、热情、个人雄心
options, like means that you're selfish and means that you are a bad daughter and a bad sister and a bad friend and whatever. And that is just like complete bull crap. Like it's just not true. Life is something that, yes, you need to live within community and you want to be close to your family and friends, but it is actually incomplete about you and completely about what you are really striving to do and what you really want to do. You, I think, also need to do this for the younger you and also the future you, who is really betting on you having the courage to just stick with what you want to do and just deal with maybe some of the criticism and some of the disappointment a little bit longer to realize a dream and also to realize a future way of living where there
选项，似乎就意味着你很自私，意味着你是一个糟糕的女儿、一个糟糕的姐妹、一个糟糕的朋友，诸如此类。这简直是胡扯。这根本不是真的。生活是一件这样的事：是的，你需要融入社群生活，你希望与家人和朋友保持亲近，但这实际上并不完全关乎你，也完全不关乎你真正努力去做的事和你真正想做的事。我认为，你也需要为了年幼的自己，以及为了未来的自己去做这件事，未来的那个你正押注于你有勇气坚持自己想做的事，并再多应对一会儿别人的批评和失望，去实现一个梦想，同时也实现一种未来的生活方式，在那里
will be less guilt about this. You will be more discerning and more able to make the decisions that are best for you and hopefully your family will understand. You know, families always say like, we just want you to be happy. Sometimes it can feel like they don't, really, but I think that they do. And just being able to have that conversation with your friends and with your family, just being like, I love you guys. I miss you, but I have to do this for me and finding ways to stay in touch with them so they still feel a part of your life and not neglected is super, super important.
对于这件事的内疚会减少。你会更有辨别力，更有能力做出最适合你的决定，而且希望你的家人也能理解。你知道，家人们总是说：“我们只希望你快乐。”有时可能会觉得他们并不是真的这么想，但我认为他们是的。只要能和你的朋友、家人进行那样的对话，说：“我爱你们。我很想念你们，但我必须为自己这样做”，并找到与他们保持联系的方法，让他们仍然觉得自爱是你的生活的一部分而没有被忽视，这是超级超级重要的。
Also, it sounds like the time will come when you can. move back closer to your family and when you will be neighborly and you will be close to them and perhaps you're going to miss this time quite a lot and you're going to wish that you had seen it out to its full potential. I definitely know like when the time is right the time is right and you will sense it and you will feel it and cutting any chapter short early for expectations or what you think other people want from you or for factors beyond your own deep desire. I might leave you with a little bit of regret and wishing that you had lived out the rest of that period and feeling like the door kind of closed a little bit too early and you're a little bit discombobulated.
另外，听起来总有一天你会搬回离家人更近的地方，那时你将成为一个好邻居，你会离他们很近，也许你会非常怀念这段时光，并希望自己当初能把它坚持到最好。我绝对知道，当时机成熟时，时机就是成熟了，你会感觉到，你会感受到它，为了迎合期望、或你认为别人希望你成为的样子、或为了超越你内心深处渴望的因素而过早地结束任何章节，可能会留给你一丝遗憾，让你希望自己能把那段时期过完，并且感觉大门关得有点太早了，让你感到有些不知所措。
So I think you're making a great choice by just finishing out, closing out this chapter. Make sure that you just like keep the communication lines open with family that like you love them and you care about them. And maybe this is in your future plans. But like right now you need to do this for you. and recognize that it's not selfish. It's actually incredibly unselfish for yourself and for future generations. And if you want to have kids, to really learn and reinforce,
所以我认为你选择完成并结束这个章节是一个极好的决定。确保你只是与家人保持沟通渠道畅通，让他们知道你爱他们、你在乎他们。也许这就在你未来的计划中。但现在你必须为自己这样做。并且要认识到这不是自私。这实际上对你自己和后代来说是极其无私的。如果你想生孩子，去真正学习和强化这一点，
and especially you as a psychologist as well, to know that making decisions that are best for you is actually entirely part of life's plan and entirely normal and an really important part of the developmental process that you learn how to do this and how to, live beyond the expectations that others have for you. So I hope that advice is helpful. And yeah, I could listen to your South African accent all day. It's there's something about, I can't describe it, just does something like crunchy and fun to my mind. So best of luck.
尤其是你作为一名心理学家，也应该知道，做出最适合你的决定完全是人生计划的一部分，完全是正常的，也是发展过程中非常重要的一部分，你得学会如何做到这一点，以及如何超越他人对你的期望生活。所以我希望这些建议对你有所帮助。是的，我可以一整天都听你的南非口音。有些东西，我无法形容，它就是对我的大脑产生了一种酥脆而有趣的奇妙效果。祝你好运。
Okay, we have time for one final question for our listener episode. Here it is. Hi. I'm so excited that you're doing this segment again. So I'm, I am a 26-year-old female living in the United States. I don't know if you need that information. But my dilemma is that I'm looking at moving in with my partner, and something that scares me so much is, like, finally moving away from home. And I know not every 20-something-year-old has that fear. A lot of people just kind of jump and go.
好了，我们还有时间回答听众特辑的最后一个问题。就是这个。嗨。我太兴奋了，你又在做这个环节了。所以我，我是一名住在美国的26岁女性。我不知道你是否需要这些信息。但我的困惑是，我正考虑和伴侣同居，而让我感到非常害怕的一件事是，终于要搬离家了。我知道并非每个二十几岁的人都有这种恐惧。很多人只是纵身一跃就搬走了。
but I'm wondering what the psychology or if there's any psychology behind that, like, why certain people are scared to move away from home and why certain people just can't wait to move away from home. I'm curious to hear your thoughts and hope this helps other people that might be feeling the same way. I actually think this is the best question to end on. I love that we had that parallel of somebody who's like, oh, I'm living away and I feel kind of guilty. and then somebody being like, oh, I really want to move, but I don't know how to process that. And then somebody who has moved back. Like, that's kind of a coincidence that happened. I didn't realize that I chose this theme of like, I guess moving and family, which is something
但我在想，这背后是否有心理学原因，或者是否有任何心理学原理来解释，为什么某些人害怕搬离家，而另一些人却迫不及待地想要搬离家。我很好奇你的想法，也希望这能帮助到其他可能有同样感受的人。我其实觉得这是最适合作为结束的问题。我喜欢我们有这样一个平行对比：一个人说：“哦，我住在外面，我感到有点内疚。”另一个人则说：“哦，我真的很想搬出去，但我不知道该如何处理这种情绪。”然后又有一个人搬回来了。这算是一种巧合吧。我没有意识到我选择了这样一个关于搬家和家庭的主题，这让我一直在深深思考。不过无论如何，谢谢你打电话进来。谢谢你留言。又是一个美丽的声音。对此是有解释的。这既相当复杂，也很简单。我认为这实际上归结于我们如何看待风险，
that's heavy on my mind. But anyways, thank you for dialing in. Thank you for leaving a call. Another beautiful voice. There is an explanation for this. And it's rather complex, but also simple. And I think it really comes down to how we view rich. risk and our tolerance for uncertainty and our tolerance for new novel experiences.
以及我们对不确定性的容忍度，还有我们对新奇体验的容忍度。
So each of us basically has a risk profile of how tolerant, how comfortable we feel with things that are scary and things that are new. We have risk-loving, risk-averse, risk-neutral. Risk-loving, that describes the kind of person you talked about who was like, cool, I turned 17, I'm turned 18, I'm out of here. I don't have a plan. I don't even have a plane ticket. I don't even have a suitcase,
所以我们每个人基本上都有一个风险档案，关于我们对可怕的事物和新事物的容忍度和舒适度有多高。我们有热爱风险的、回避风险的、风险中立的。热爱风险，这描述了你刚才谈到的那种人，他们就像是：酷，我17岁了，我18岁了，我离开这里。我没有计划。我甚至没有机票。我甚至没有手提箱，
but I know I want to go somewhere. These are the people who are like, like you just, I admire them so much. Like they're always on the road. They're always ready to make new choices. One of my friends, Gracie is like that. And I just think she's so cool. It's not who I am.
但我知道我想去某个地方。这些人就像是——你简直太让我钦佩了。他们总是在路上。他们随时准备做出新的选择。我的朋友格蕾西就是这样的人。我只是觉得她太酷了。这不是我。
I think I'm more risk-neutral. I can kind of take it or leave it. And it sounds like you might be a little bit risk-averse in this situation. The fear factor and, you know, some of the discomfort of change just weighs on you a little bit more heavy. There's nothing wrong with that. It's actually completely normal. That's just how you are. And you're probably trying to be a bit more conscious and think about this a little bit more and make sure that that's the right decision. And I think that that's actually a sign that it is. The fact that you are thinking about it so deeply, the fact that you are so invested in ensuring that, you know, this is going to work out with your partner is beautiful.
我想我更倾向于风险中立。我可以接受也可以放弃。听起来你在这种情况下可能有点风险规避。恐惧因素，你知道的，改变带来的一些不适感对你来说更重一些。这没有什么不对。这其实完全正常。你就是这样的人。你可能只是想更有意识一些，多考虑一下这是否是正确的决定。我认为这其实是一个它是正确决定的迹象。你思考得如此深入，你如此投入地去确保，你知道的，这将会和你的伴侣有一个好结果，这很美妙。
I'm not going to lie and say that moving away from your family is going to be necessarily the easiest thing in the world, especially since you've been there for so long, like 20 something years. It might not be better. It's just going to be different and it's just going to be an incredible time. Don't focus so much on the downsides. Really keep your vision on the positives. Stocking your pantry. getting to decorate your home with the person that you love, getting to be naked on your couch, whenever you want to be, getting to just make it your own and make it like, you know how your
我不会撒谎说搬离你的家庭必然是世界上最容易的事，特别是既然你在那里呆了那么久，二十多年。这可能不会更好。它只是会有所不同，而且这将是一段不可思议的时光。不要把注意力过多放在消极方面。真正把你的目光锁定在积极的方面。囤满食品储藏室。和你爱的人一起装饰你的家，随时随地想光着身子在沙发上就光着身子，真正把它变成你自己的空间，让它变得像——你知道你的
parents created a great home for you and one that you love and being able to create that for yourself and for you and your partner's little family and if you get pets and when friends come over, like it's just such a beautiful young adult feeling that I'm so excited for you to have. When there are hard times, just make sure you have rituals that maybe tie you back to the comforts that you really enjoyed about living with your family and that were really amazing about being close to them. Make sure you've got those recipes for those home cooked meals so that you can make that for you even, you know, miles away. Make that for yourself even miles away. Bring something special from home. Maybe it's like,
父母为你创造了一个美好的家，一个你所热爱的家，而你能够为你自己以及你和伴侣的小家庭创造这样的家，如果你养了宠物，当朋友们过来时，这真是一种美好的年轻成年人的感觉，我太为你感到兴奋了。当遇到困难时期时，只要确保你拥有一些仪式感，也许能将你重新连接到你真正享受的与家人生活在一起的舒适感，以及与他们亲近时的美好。确保你拥有那些家常菜的谱子，这样你甚至可以在几英里外也能为自己做出来。即使在几英里外也要为自己做那道菜。带一些家里特有的东西。也许像是一条
a duvet, maybe it's like a blanket, a rug, a couple of photos. Integrate like this old life with this new life that you're entering into because it is all interconnected and this is just the next iteration and evolution of you as a person and so much growth is going to happen. It's going to be amazing. Also living with your partner is a blast. Like it's like having a sleepover every night. And I feel like in the first three months, you're going to be just like so excited and over
羽绒被，也许是一条毯子，一块地毯，几张照片。将这种旧生活与你正在迈入的新生活融合在一起，因为这一切都是相互关联的，这只是你作为一个人的下一次迭代和演变，并且会有大量的成长发生。这将会太棒了。和伴侣一起生活也很爽。就像每天晚上都在开睡衣派对。我觉得在前三个月里，你会兴奋到极点，
the moon that you're not going to realize that you're missing anybody or that you're missing anything. So I just keep saying good luck, but I really mean it to all of you. Like, good luck. You guys are just so wonderful and beautiful and just ask such beautiful, emotionally intelligent, earnest, fabulous questions. So I appreciate you guys going to the effort to want to be a part of the show and for being the best guest that I ever get the chance to have. You guys are such good guess. I don't know how many questions we are answered, all eight, nine of you and all the others, all the others of you who also submitted questions. Thank you so much. If you have any advice for any of these people, drop it in the comments below. If you've listened this far, if you have a
以至于你都不会意识到你在想念任何人或任何东西。所以我只想说祝你们好运，我是真心对你们所有人的。祝你好运。你们真的是太棒了、太美好了，并且提出了如此精彩、情商极高、真诚且绝妙的问题。所以我很感激你们付出努力想要成为节目的一部分，并成为我有机会拥有的最好的嘉宾。你们真的是太棒的嘉宾了。我不知道我们回答了多少问题，所有八、九个提问的你们以及所有其他也提交了问题的人。非常感谢你们。如果你对这些人中的任何一个有任何建议，请把它留在下面的评论里。如果你听到了这里，如果你有
further question, maybe I'll spend some time answering questions in the comments, but also keep the advice going. If you have experience with any of these things, what tips would you give these people? Make sure as well that you are following us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. If you want to see more behind the scene stuff, if you want to be able to contribute to future episodes like this, that is where you are going to find out about it. But until next time, stay safe. Be kind. Be gentle to yourself. And thank you for listening. We will talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows. what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not
更多的问题，也许我会花一些时间在评论里回答问题，但也请继续提供建议。如果你有其中任何事情的经验，你会给这些人什么建议呢？同时确保你在Instagram上关注我们，账号是That Psychology Podcast。如果你想看更多幕后花絮，如果你想为未来这样的小节做出贡献，那就是你找到它的地方。但直到下一次，保重。保持善良。对自己温柔一点。谢谢收听。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听由你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人科尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难开悟》。这个空间探讨黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极其不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在和一个懂行的有资质的专业人士交谈。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是
to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the signs of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
好惹的。这并不意味着你拥有这种能力，你就必须去使用它。在iHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难开悟》。2%。这就是有自动扶梯可用时，仍选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中精神坚韧、健身和建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端脱胎换骨，成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的自己。收听《2%》。
That's TWA% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends.
这就是在IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约定时，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他不会就这样逃脱惩罚的。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女朋友们。
Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe. On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J.
收听《女朋友》。相信我，宝贝。在Iheart radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《回味过去》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我和我来说是一个重要的时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。我是萨姆·J。
And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick you here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year.
我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选你，回顾发生的事情，并试着通过我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员和最喜欢的作家，来理解我们是如何熬过那段时光的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔聊80年代。那是疯狂的一年。那是疯狂的一年。
I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Lerner. Correct? I doctored the test ones.
我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的一年了。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《回味过去》。在2023年，美国广播公司（ABC）《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你伪造了这个特定的测试两次，勒纳女士。对吗？我伪造了一次测试。
It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Marencini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
这需要一大批互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·吉莱斯皮和迈克尔·马伦奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《受困的爱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着赛季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯最终面临后果。
Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《受困的爱》播客。这是一个IHeart播客。保证有人类参与。这集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。